coffee
has been keeping us awake
for centuries has coffee been around for
centuries oh yeah i thought if that
century was a thousand years what's a
thousand millennia
hey everybody it's katie and i'm back
with my husband chris hi we realized
that we've
been missing coffee a lot
i did the pun
we've been missing going to starbucks
and getting that weekly pick-me-up yes i
thought i could replicate our starbucks
order for tomorrow morning oh that
sounds fine we should do the the salted
cold form cold brew oh the salted cream
salted cream cold it's this oh no it's
cold brew with salted cream cold foam
and a lemon loaf yes that sounds great i
feel bad i'm not doing anything to help
uh you have real work i do i do i work
this is my job
[Music]
do you give me finger guns
so to get started i'm going to make the
lemon loaf first i have a loaf pan here
this one is
9x5 but a 9x4 i think should be fine as
well grease this guy up
and then i'm going to add some parchment
we're going to set this to the side next
we're going to cream our butter and
sugar we're going to do one six softened
butter and a cup and a quarter of sugar
mix this until it's nice and fluffy
about three to four minutes
all right so i'm going to add in my eggs
now these i've let come up to room
temperature it's important that all the
ingredients you
it's important that all of the
ingredients you use today are at room
temperature this is going to keep the
batter from breaking and ensure you just
make an awesome loaf
we're doing three eggs for this recipe
and you'll want to add them one at a
time
make sure you scrape down the sides of
your bowls in between the mixing so that
everything is getting incorporated
evenly
all right we're going to set him off to
the side and in a smaller bowl add sour
cream now that might seem weird but this
is gonna help make this cake super moist
and have a really yummy tang and then i
have fresh lemon juice one tablespoon
vanilla extract we'll mix this guy up
we're gonna set this off to the side as
well now we're gonna add our dry
ingredients i've got some all-purpose
flour a little bit of baking powder and
a teaspoon of salt whisk this up perfect
okay we're gonna bring back in our eggs
and butter and sugar we've got our sour
cream also on the side we're gonna
alternate mixing these in one at a time
so we don't over mix the batter and this
is gonna make sure that our loaf is nice
and fluffy and doesn't get tough and
dense tip tipperoo tipperoo
that's what my new tips are called wow
so i'm going to add about a tablespoon
of lemon zest you want to make sure when
you're zesting you don't go down to the
white part of the rind because it's
really bitter and
i think that that
is a tablespoon bam i'm gonna just
gently fold this in
now that we've incorporated our lemon
zest pour this into the loaf pan
smooth that out okay
let's bake this at 350 degrees
fahrenheit for about 50 to 60 minutes
just until i can put a toothpick in and
nothing comes up with it let's bake my
little baby
bam our beautiful lemon loaf has baked
it has cooled for about an hour and now
i'm gonna make a lemon icing to go on
top sift powdered sugar this is just
going to get rid of any clumps and make
sure we have a perfectly smooth icing
add some milk and most importantly some
lemon juice and then we'll take our
spatula and we'll just mix that right up
you should use a whisk not a spatula i
don't know why i did this whisk it up to
get out any of those clumps once this is
all combined drizzle it over the top
and then you can just take your spatula
and smooth it around so that everything
is covered nicely i'm going to let this
glaze set for about 30 minutes then i'm
going to put some plastic wrap over it
and keep it on my counter overnight all
right let's get working on the drink
the reason i like cold brew better than
hot coffee is the hot water can actually
bring out those bitter acidic notes in
your coffee while cold brew has this
smooth taste and it is super easy to
make i have my six cups of water add my
two cups of coffee try not to spill it
all over your counter once you've added
your coffee stir it up okay i'm gonna go
put some plastic wrap on this stick it
in the fridge and move on to making some
yummy caramel syrup that's gonna go in
our cold brew we're in a new location
what am i doing so first thing we need
to do is add sugar and then we're gonna
do two tablespoons of water have the
heat on medium low wait three minutes
for all of the sugar to dissolve now
that the sugar is completely dissolved
we're gonna turn the heat up to medium
and cook it for about five minutes
undisturbed just until we get that amber
caramel color so you're gonna turn the
heat off add in a quarter cup of water
whoa
and you're gonna stir that in
just keep mixing it until it kind of
comes together i'm gonna go let this
cool put it in a container and we'll use
it tomorrow
[Music]
good morning so to finish our cold brew
i have a bowl i also have a fine mesh
strainer
and i have a coffee filter place it
inside my strainer and then we're just
gonna pour
our cold brew over it and just to show
you guys it is
slowly dripping through
kind of an awkward sound
but i'm a child
so just let it happen
it might take a little while but it is
worth it okay so we've poured our last
bit and i don't you guys can see there's
all this sludge at the bottom i once put
this down the sink i clogged the whole
drain i had to go buy a drain sink don't
do it okay our pitcher is clean our
coffee has been strained i'm gonna add
this back to our pitcher
definitely try your coffee and if it's
way too strong just add a little bit of
water i'm gonna go put this in the
fridge and we're gonna prep our final
element
it is the best part of this drink and
it's basically like a sweet salty cloud
on top of rich
caramel coffee it is so good so to get
started we'll do a half a cup of whole
milk
a half a cup of heavy whipping cream
sugar
a quarter teaspoon salt this is an
immersion blender it's just gonna make
sure we get that
thick beautiful foam we want on the top
and here we go
now that our foam is ready it's time to
assemble our drink so i'm first gonna
get two glasses fill them with ice
and a little bit of our cold brew
i'm gonna leave enough room at the top
for the cream
and then i have our caramel syrup that
we made yesterday i'm just gonna add a
little bit of that into here we'll give
these guys a stir
mix that in
and then we're gonna take a big spoon of
our foam place that right on top
chris it's breakfast
okay chris
this is your breakfast it looks like you
took it off the shelf from an actual
starbucks it has the icing it's even the
same color brown on the outside how does
the drink look the foam looks perfect it
looks it looks exactly like the real
drink it really does oh what do i get
what price do i get you can choose what
we watch on tv for the next
today
[Laughter]
cheers thank you so much this looks
amazing
that tastes so good you gotta you've
gotta
good
that's really good i will say that is
really yummy frosting is delicious thank
you so much you're welcome
welcome to starbucks drive-through gonna
take your order yes i'll have a cold
brew cold foam cold cream i don't know
what you're saying give me something to
look at
oh yes
[Music]
you